believe it or not there's a blacksmith
in Hollywood who specializes in making
real swords for films and TV yes
actual swords for stars and stunt actors
alike to cut slice and swing at each
other sure in some instances rubber
swords are used like when an actor does
stunts that require falling but as
high-definition video has improved using
authentic looking swords has become more
important it needs to be real so you can
go in close you can see it also if an
actor picks up a sword he has that
tactile feedback of the sword in his
hand and working with it as opposed to
holding a baton and emulating on a green
screen what's supposed to be happening
so it makes a big difference Jack
Sparrow played Zorro Peter Pan and
countless other movie stars use a sword
as their weapon of choice but to achieve
an authentic look plastic or rubber
swords simply won't do forget about a
prop house these swords are created in a
real blacksmith shop the authenticity
and speed with which these swords are
made can only be done by a real
blacksmith like Tony Swan I'm a Smith
I'm a blacksmith I'm a blade Smith I'm a
silversmiths I also work in copper and
tin I hit things with a hammer so that's
basically my job swords made from real
metal being heated beaten grinded beaten
some more quenched
and polished all four on screen accuracy
for over 30 years tony's been making
iconic weapons and armor and his shop
sword and the stone he has over 200
feature films and TV shows under his
belt Legend of Zorro and the mask of
zorro I made the principal swords for
Antonio Banderas for Zorro I did Pirates
of the Caribbean I did Pirates one two
and three and four he worked on the
sword and that throwable glaive thingy
for blade as well as I worked on hook I
made the hook for the movie hook as well
as the swords and background swords I
know it's not a sword but he did the
hook from hook and that's pretty cool it
starts with production sharing their
sword needs and working with the
blacksmith on the design it's also
crucial to decide what the sword will be
made from a lot of times film will
contact me and say hey we we have a
movie its 12th century Scotland and we
need to make a sword what would you
recommend or this is our design how
would you go about making it we kind of
work together with the prop master the
costume designer the set decorator and
the production designer a lot of times
I'll have a input into what we make
Zorro sword a case in point it was
actually a curved hunting sword from the
1500s that was in the Tower of London
and the Wallace Collection in London and
i cobbled those together and made it
into a more of a rapier than shortened
that down and embellished it with
details from both swords once the design
is decided multiple versions of the same
sword will be created depending on how
the sword will be used on-screen a more
authentic real steel sword is needed for
close-up action shots while an aluminum
sword will be used for wider shots and
sequences that require more movement
this is the hero Jack Sparrow sword this
is formed out of steel forged steel
he'll two ebony grip this is not a hero
pieces the background piece this is the
stunt weapon this one feels way lighter
it is way lighter the hero piece is out
of forged steel for the hilt and ebony
for the grip this is identical from gear
down the blade is identical looking at
going up here but this is made out of
aluminum this is an aluminum rapier it's
lightweight it's a doll it's not going
to cut anyone but it has great
properties goes back to true the sword
starts as layers of dissimilar metal
welded together in this instance some of
the layers are made from an industrial
bandsaw blade originally use the cut
down redwood trees yo the metal is
heated up then hammered flat either by
hand or power hammer then fold it over
and flattened a few more times the sword
is ground down to its shape and is heat
treated in an electric oven this process
brings a blade up to 1600 degrees and
then it's quenched in oil
this hardens the steel without this step
the play would crack or shatter while in
use after that more grinding about Tony
also makes the grip hilt and pommel it's
all put together and voila you have a
sword scene here my guy Brian swings the
real sword its weight and authenticity
makes for a realistic looking swing and
action you can only get with a real
sword in case you couldn't tell this is
a pretty dangerous environment
everything is either hot sharp or
poisonous notice I'm not in any of these
shots that's because I'm behind the
camera man what makes me unique is the
speed at which I can create these pieces
I'll put a thirty-five swords together
in a day for film production the most
swords on it made for a single
production has probably got to be last
summer I made about six hundred swords
predominantly aluminum weapons for the
big battle scenes but the crazy thing
about that I was working on both Master
and Commander and Pirates of the
Caribbean concurrently so between those
three productions who did a thousand
swords and with that Tony's ability as a
blacksmith the speed authenticity and
the detail with which you can create
swords is impossible to duplicate
[Applause]
[Music]
you